this is very important to you tell us
about it it's called visible there's is
for series for me for four segments and
it's it pretty chronic chronic chronic
company chronicles Thank You chronicles
good lord
it chronicles the history of LGBT cube
people in TV so it shows how important
it is to be seen and to be visible on
television and tell our stories because
it doesn't act change and we have seen
that throughout history how you talk
about a lot of pivotal moments you got a
lot of great completely to participate -
yes yes everyone from from Tim Gunn
Wilson Cruz is also an EP we have a
course Ellen's story and then there's
you know Billie Jean King and just lots
of people but Anderson Cooper a lot of
politicians but it's really important is
to see how far we've come and where we
need to go really yeah it's really
touching it's pretty amazing when you
just even think about how 20 years ago
25 years ago which I know there's a
young people watching they think well
that's a long time ago it really wasn't
that long a time ago there you didn't
see anybody who represented any any of
that spectrum on television right and I
mean as a kid I remember watching TV and
because we didn't have representation I
would make you know we would just make
up gay people you know like one of the
Charlie's Angels she was gay Sabrina was
gay a little Brady Bunch
yeah goalless yeah yeah
boy I watched those shows differently
now well it's it's a very cool project
visible out on television is available
now on Apple TV plus and so you got to
check that out
Wanda Sykes thank you so much
[Applause]